the fire movement otherwise known as
financial independence retire early
changed our lives in ways that we had
never thought possible before
five years ago we came across dave
ramsey and we were motivated like never
before to reach financial independence
with the goal of early retirement
we sold many of our possessions
worked overtime almost every single week
cut out many of our expenses
and worked diligently to get out of debt
for the first time in our lives we
realized that we could take ownership of
our finances and build a future we
desire
one where we could be financially freed
from the rat race and actually have time
for family friends and activities that
we enjoy
one where we could give more and make a
greater impact
one in which we could be free to work on
projects and hobbies simply because we
choose to and not because we
have to make money
one where money isn't a barrier to
spending more time with our children
in many ways i am incredibly thankful
for having come across the fire movement
even much more so that my husband joined
me
it led us to minimalism and being
content with less and simplicity
it freed me from my horrible shopping
habits which i share more in detail in
my video the seven dumbest purchases i
made in my early twenties
and it fueled the fire that we needed to
build our first home a small home but a
monster of a project for two people who
had never done such a thing before
we have yet to reach our financial goals
but something has changed in me now
and that is that
i'm okay with that
you see it all sounds pretty on the
outside
we built a home and got out of debt
however we sacrificed much to get there
as a nurse i worked 12 hour shifts and
was working overtime every single week
until the point that i could no longer
manage at 9 months pregnant
once our daughter was born we sacrificed
time with her
i overworked my body trying to do more
and frustrated because i couldn't do it
fast enough
my husband injured his back and spent
sleepless nights because of uncontrolled
pain
and thousands of dollars to get
treatment
needless to say he could not work during
that time and we were unable to work on
the house
i'm incredibly thankful for the home
that we have because it was built
through literal blood sweat and tears
and it was not without sacrifice
i am now a mom of two young children i
still have a full-time job but my
perspective has changed
greatly
i now long to savor simple moments
to explore the beauty of slow
intentional living
to allow myself to spend money on myself
every now and then without feeling guilt
to give myself permission to say no to
the constant text messages requesting
for me to work overtime and most
importantly to enjoy each day as though
it were my last
my patience changed my perspective on
life
you see
i now work as a hospice nurse
every day that i work i am faced with
the concept of death and dying
i assist patients who are at the end of
life to better manage their symptoms so
that they can live their life to their
fullest for however long that might be
and through these individuals i have
learned that it is not the big
accomplishments and hurdles that we
cross that truly bring us joy in the
long run
for my patients
it is the simplest of moments that bring
tears of joy to their eyes
it's being able to be at home with their
puppy on their lap it's being able to
see their grandchildren laugh and play
it's controlling the nausea just enough
to enjoy their loved morning coffee
it's seeing a bird outside the window
it's being surrounded by the people they
love most
looking back i realized that i became so
obsessed with doing more achieving more
and doing it all faster that i
sacrificed the thing that i most
treasure
in order to accomplish a goal at some
point in the future
a time
that may never happen
i still hold value to the categories
give save spend and invest but i now
realize that there is so much more to it
than that
that life is precious
that every day i am able to work my
patients deserve my complete presence
and attention
that i ought to work on the things that
i enjoy and have time for myself
that every day with my family is a gift
that every day i walk and breathe
i am blessed in some way
i hope this video encourages you to not
only place a focus on creating financial
goals and seek a specific target a
specific destination
but to enjoy the ride
to enjoy the process of getting there
when hiking to the top of the mountain
the view is incredible but don't just
enjoy the view at the top
be sure to enjoy the sights on the way
up
and this is why i quit the fire movement
in favor of slow and intentional living
if you enjoyed this video please give it
a thumbs up and share with your friends
and don't forget to subscribe so you
won't miss when i post a new video
i thank you so much for watching until
next time